who wrote these these are too hard
[Music]
central park trivia here we go question
one how many acres is central park
a million uh it's multiple choices
hey 843 acres b 716 acres c
900 acres they're all so far from a
million
uh 900 acres closest to a million
eight forty three so nice all right all
right that's all right
what is the name of this sculpture in
the heart of central park
a angel of life b angel of waters c
angel of nature i think that's the angel
of waters
bow come on all right oh switching oh
switching switching
which of these is not an area of central
park
a strawberry fields b the roseway
c cedar hill d sheep meadow
go man i don't know i'm gonna i'm gonna
sheep meadow it's not d you know this is
cedar hill
oh i only know it's not d let's say
let's say c
the road b three there's nothing in all
of central park called the road there's
now
can somebody fix that yeah we have a
show called central park great so i was
right
yep how many benches are there in
central park
uh a 3000 b 6000 c nine thousand
i'm out we're gonna go with b
b six thousand right the minute
the central park zoo here we go is known
to have penguins as one of its featured
animals which
of these is not one of the species of
penguins
currently on display a the chinstrap
penguin
b the macaroni penguins see the royal
penguin
d the gentoo penguin there's no such
thing as a macaroni
agree with you on that bro the royal
family
us
[Music]
you